welcome back to understanding Quantum information and computation my name is John watus and I'm the technical director for education at IBM
Quantum this is lesson number 14 of the series and it's the second lesson of the fourth unit which is on Quantum error
correction in the previous lesson we took a first look at Quantum error correction including the nine Cubit Shore code which establishes that
Quantum error correction is possible in theory we also discussed the discretization of Errors which allows us
to correct for arbitrary Quantum errors on cubits by effectively projecting them onto bit flips and phase
flips in this lesson we'll discuss the stabilizer formalism which is a mathematical tool through which we can
specify and analyze a broad class of quantum error correcting codes known as stabilizer codes this includes the 9 Cubit Shore
code along with many other examples including codes that are likely to be much better suited to real world Quantum
Computing devices than the shore Cod code not every Quantum error correcting code is a stabilizer code but many are
including every example that we'll see in this series there are certainly interesting and potentially useful Quantum error
correcting codes that aren't stabilizer codes but they tend to be rather more complicated and in any case there's no
question that the stabilizer formalism is a Cornerstone in the foundation of quantum error correction and we'll be
relying heavily upon it for the remainder of the unit here's a brief overview of the lesson we'll start out with a short discussion
of poly matrices and tensor products of poly matrices which can represent both operations on cubits as well as
measurements of cubits as I'll explain and in this context we often refer to them as observables we'll then go back and have
a second look at the repetition code and we'll see how we can describe it through poly operations and observables and that will both inform
and lead into a general discussion of stabilizer codes including several examples basic properties of stabilizer
codes and how we can go about performing the fundamental tasks of encoding detecting errors and correcting those
errors we'll begin the lesson with a brief discussion of poly operations mainly to set the stage for the
stabilizer formalism but also to observe a few key facts and establish some basic terminology first here are the poly
matrices including the 2x2 identity Matrix as well as the three non-identity poly matrices which will denote by
capital X X Y and Z throughout the remainder of the series all four of these matrices are both unitary and herian and we can
identify them with operations on a cubit including operations we might choose to perform as well as errors as we
discussed in the previous lesson the non-identity poly matrices X Y and Z anticommute with one another
meaning that XY is equal to -1 * YX XZ is equal to negative ZX and YZ is equal
to negative z y and you can easily check these relations by doing the multiplications these anti-commutation
relations are very simple but they're critically important in the stabilizer formalism and elsewhere and specifically
as we'll see these minus signs that pop out when we exchange The Ordering of two different non-identity poly matrices in a product correspond precisely to the
detection of errors in the stabilizer formalism we also have the multiplication rules listed here each
polymatrix is its own inverse which is consistent with the fact that they're both unitary and herian and if you multiply any two different non-identity
poly matrices together you'll always get plus or minus I times the remaining non-identity
polymatrix in particular up to a global phase Y is equivalent to X time Z which explains our focus on x and z errors in
Quantum error correction X represents a bit flip Z represents a phase flip and so up to a global phase y represents
both of these errors occurring on the same Cubit these four matrices all represent
operations or errors or the absence of an error on a single Cubit but it's often convenient to tensor them together
to perform operations or errors on multiple cubits as a point of terminology whenever we refer to an N Cubit poly
operation we mean a tensor product of any n poly matrices such as the examples shown
here it's also common to use the term poly operation when there's a global phase but to keep things as simple as possible
I'm going to use the term poly operation to mean simply a tensor product of poly matrices the weight of an incubate poly
operation is simply the number of non-identity poly matrices in the tensor product for example the n-fold tensor
product of the 2 x two identity Matrix with itself is a weight zero poly operation a tensor product of two polyx
matrices and a whole bunch of identity matrices has weight two and so on intuitively speaking the weight of an N
Cubit poly operation is the number of cubits on which it acts non-trivially and it's typical that Quantum error correcting codes are
designed so that they can detect and correct errors represented by poly operations up to a certain weight we can
think about poly operations in various ways including as operations performed intentionally by Quantum Gates as well
as errors and we'll also see shortly that poly operations can describe measurements sometimes it's also useful
to think about poly operations as generators of certain sets in an algebraic sense that you may recognize
if you're familiar with group theory if you're not familiar with group Theory that's okay it's really not essential
for this lesson but if you're interested in studying Quantum error correction in Greater depth you may find that some
basic group theory is very helpful for doing that anyway let's suppose that P1 through PR are n Cubit poly operations
so P1 is an ncit poly operation P2 is an ncit poly operation and so on when we refer to the set generated by
P1 through p r what we mean is the set of all matrices that we can obtain by multiplying these matrices together in
any combination and in any order we choose taking each one as many times as we like we'll see a few examples in just
a moment but first let me mention the notation that we use to denote this set the set generated by P1 through PR and
it's P1 through PR separated by commas inside of angled brackets it does kind of look like we could easily confuse
this notation with direct notation but that doesn't generally happen and this is the traditional notation in group
Theory here's an example of the set generated by X Y and Z so n is equal to one in this example because there are no
tensor products and we're taking all three non-identity poly matrices as generators it turns out that there are
16 matrices that can be generated by forming products that include these three matrices and you can reason this
through the multiplication rules that we saw earlier specifically we can of course get X Y and Z as well as the identity
and in fact we can also get any of these four matrices time I 1 or negative I and that's
it this set is commonly known as the poly group we could also consider the set
generated by just x and z and we end up getting half of the poly group in this case
and one final example at least for now we can consider the set generated by X tensor x and z tensor Z so n is equal to
two in this case and we end up getting just four elements this time owing to the fact that X tensor x and z tensor Z
commute with one another poly matrices and N Cubit poly operations more generally describe
unitary operations whether they're errors or they're intentional but they also describe
measurements to be more precise starting with just the three non-identity poly matrices we can associate each of these
matrices with a projective measurement defined in terms of its igen values and igen vectors and here on the screen we
have spectral decompositions of these matrices that will help to clarify this in essence when we refer to an X
measurement a y measurement or a z measurement we mean the projective measurement defined by the projections
onto the igen spaces of these matrices and commonly we think about the igen value vales as being the corresponding
measurement outcomes for example an X measurement is a measurement with respect to the plus
minus basis of a cubit or alternatively we can describe it by the set containing the projections Kat plus BR plus and K
minus bra minus a z measurement on the other hand is nothing more than a standard basis
measurement although like I said we sometimes identify the igen values with the measurement outcomes and if we do
that then the outcomes are plus and minus one as opposed to 0 and one respectively we can in fact do something
along these lines for arbitrary hermi matrices and the term observable is commonly used in this situation for poly
matrices and encubate poly operations more generally we can perform such measurements non-destructively using
phase estimation and just to be sure that this diagram is clear here we're performing the measurements non-destructively on
the top Cubit whereas the bottom cubit is always initialized to a plus state or in other words a hadamard applied to a
zero State because that's how phase estimation Works notice that because the I values
are just plus one and minus one in this case we only need one control Cubit which is the bottom cubid in this
diagram any more than that would just be a waste because there is only one bit of precision to worry about the ion value
is either plus one or minus one and the measurement is already perfect just like this the outcome of this measurement by
the way meaning the standard basis measurement in the circuit will be zero for the plus one igen value outcome
which corresponds to the plus state in the case of an X observable and the outcome is one for the minus one ion
value or the minus state in this case everything I just said extends naturally to ncit poly operations
provided that we keep in mind that when we think about an observable we're talking about measuring the igen values
not measuring with respect to a basis of igen vectors for example consider the two
Cubit poly operation Z tensor Z once again there are two igen values plus one and minus one so the
measurement is described by two projections notice in particular that the measurement that we associate with
this observable is not the same as measuring both cubits with a z measurement or in other words a standard basis measurement but rather it's a two
outcome projective measurement where the projections are onto the spaces spend by all of the IG vectors corresponding to
each of the two igen values plus one and minus one another way of thinking about this is that the igen values of a tensor
product are products of the IG values of the individual matricies that we're taking the tensor products of and
because negative 1 * negative 1 is the same as positive 1 * positive 1 for instance this measurement doesn't
distinguish between 0 0 and 1 one so if we were to measure say a five plus Bell state with the measurement
described by this observable we would be certain to obtain the outcome corresponding to the I Value Plus One
and the state would be unchanged as opposed to collapsing to 0 0 or 1 one which is what would happen if we
performed the standard basis measurements on the two cubits so a zensor z measurement is not
the same thing as performing to Z measurements independently but we can in fact perform measurements like this using phase
estimat in precisely the same way as before using a single control Cubit as is shown in the circuit diagram which
generalizes to any n Cubit poly operation in place of Z tensor Z when we have just Z poly matrices by
the way we can simplify the circuit like this and what this reveals which is also evident from the projections that Define
the measurement is that performing a z tensor Z measurement on two cubits is equivalent to measuring their parity
thinking in terms of the standard basis and this generalizes to the tensor product of any number of poly Z
matrices next we'll take a second look at the three-bit repetition code this time phrasing it in terms of poly
operations this will be our first rather simple example of a stabilizer code and we'll discuss how to generalize this
notion shortly but it is helpful to see how it works in this simple case first recall that when we apply the
3-bit repetition code to cubits we encode a given Cubit State Alpha 0 plus beta 1 as Alpha 0000 0 plus beta 11 1 1
and we'll give this three Cubit encoding the name Sai for convenience so by definition s is a valid three Cubit
encoding of a cubit state but if we want to check this it suffices to check that the following two equations are true the
first equation states that applying Z operations to the leftmost two cubits of s does nothing to S which is to say that
SII is an igen vector of Z tensor Z tensor Identity or just ZZ identity for short with ion value one and the second
equation is similar except that Z operations are applied to the rightmost two cubits the idea is if we think about S
as a linear combination of standard basis States then the first equation implies that we can only have non-zero coefficients for standard basis states
where the leftmost two bits have even parity or equivalently are equal and the second equation implies that we can only
have non-zero coefficients for standard basis States for which the rightmost two bits have even parity another way to think about this
is to view these two poly operations as observables and if we were to measure these two observables using the
simplified circuit I mentioned just a moment ago then we would be certain to obtain a measurement outcome corresponding to plus one igen values
because s is an igen Vector of both observables with igen value one but this simplified version of the combined
circuit for independent ly measuring the observables is none other than our parity check circuit for the 3-bit
repetition code and so we see that our two equations together are equivalent to the parity check circuit outputting 0 0
which is the syndrome that indicates that no errors have been detected the three Cubit poly operations
ZZ identity and identity ZZ are called stabilizer generators for this code and the stabilizer of the code is the set
generated by the stabilizer generators this set the stabilizer is a fundamentally important mathematical
object associated with this code and we'll discuss further the role that it plays as the lesson continues for now
I'll just point out that we could have made a different choice for the generators for instance we could have selected Z identity Z in place of either
of the generators we did select and the code and the stabilizer would be exactly the same next we'll consider bit flip
detection for the three-bit repetition code with a focus on the interactions and relationships among the poly
operations that are involved namely the stabilizer generators and the errors themselves suppose that we've encoded a
cubit using the three-bit repetition code and a bit flip error occurs on the leftmost Cubit this causes our state side to be
transformed according to the action of an X operation or X error on the leftmost Cubit as we already know we can detect
this error by performing the parody checks for the three-bit repetition code or equivalently we can measure the
encoding non-destructively treating the stabilizer generators as observables let's start with the first
stabilizer generator and see what happens our state has been affected by an X error and we'd like to understand
how the measurement of the stabilizer generator as an observable is influenced by this error x and z anticommute whereas
everything commutes with the identity Matrix and so it follows that ZZ identity anti-c commutes with X identity
identity so we get a minus sign when the order is changed and we also know that ZZ identity doesn't do anything to S
because s is a valid encoding of a cubit and valid encodings are always plus one igen vectors of both stabilizer
generators that leaves us with negative X identity identity applied to S and therefore X identity identity applied to
S is an igen Vector of ZZ identity with igen value negative one we can also do something similar
with the second stabilizer generator but this time the error commutes with the stabilizer generator and so our
Corrupted State is again an igon Vector of the stabilizer generator but this time the igen value is positive
one so our Corrupted State is an IG Vector of both stabilizer generators and whether the igen value is plus one or
minus one is determined by whether the error commutes or anti-c commutes with each stabilizer generator for the first
one the error and the stabilizer generator anticommute and for the second one they commute and it's always going to be one or the other because any two
poly operations either commute or anticommute meanwhile the actual State side doesn't really play an important
role here except for the fact that the stabilizer generators act trivially on this state so when we're thinking about the
detection of Errors we really don't need to concern ourselves with the specific encoded State all that matters is whether the error commutes or anti-c
commutes with each stabilizer generator so let's make a table that has one row for each stabilizer generator
and one column for each error here I've only included the errors corresponding to a single bit flip as
well as no error at all which is indicated by the identity tensed with itself three times we could add more columns for other errors if we wanted
but for now we'll focus on just these errors the entry in the table is either plus one or minus one depending on
whether the error and the stabilizer generator commute or anticommute so for each error in the table we can look at
the corresponding column to see how that error will transform any given encoding into a plus one or a minus one igen
vector of each stabilizer generator these columns correspond precisely to the syndrome we would obtain from the
parity checks which are equivalent to the non-destructive measurements of the stabilizer generators as
observables of course the entes in this table are plus ones and minus ones rather than zeros and ones respectively
and if you prefer you can think about the syndromes as being the corresponding binary strings rather than Columns of plus ones and minus ones but there's a
direct correspondence and just to make the connection between the syndromes and the igen values more clear and direct
I'm going to refer to these vectors of plus ones and minus ones as syndromes as before the syndromes tell
us something about whatever error took place and in particular if we know that one of these four possible errors
occurred the syndrome indicates to us which one it was and we can correct it by applying the error again if we
choose next I'll say just a little bit more about the syndromes and in particular we'll take a closer look at
their algebraic aspects our encodings are three Cubit States so they're unit vectors in an
eight dimensional complex Vector space and what the four possible syndromes do is to slice this eight dimensional space
up into four four two-dimensional subspaces meaning that the vectors in any one of these subspaces will always give us the same
syndrome in more detail this diagram illustrates how the eight-dimensional space is divided
up each stabilizer generator splits the space into two subspaces of equal Dimension namely the space of plus one
IG vectors and the space of minus one I vectors for example the plus one vectors of ZZ identity are linear combinations
of standard basis States for which the leftmost two bits have even parity and the minus one igen vectors are linear
combinations of standard basis States for which the leftmost two bits have odd parity and the situation is similar for
the other stabilizer generator except that it's the rightmost two bits rather than the leftmost two bits so these four subspaces are easy to
describe in this case owing to the fact that this is a very simple code in particular the Subspace
corresponding to the syndrome plus one +1 is is the space spend by C 000000 and K 111 which is the space of valid
encodings and that's called the code space and in general the spaces are spanned by the standard Bas of states
that are shown in the corresponding squares although it's not necessarily as clear or as easy to see the syndromes
also partition all of the three Cubit poly operations which represent the possible poly errors that could take place into four equal siiz collections
depending upon which syndrome that error would cause for example any poly operation
that commutes with both stabilizer generators results in the syndrome plus1 plus1 and among the 64 possible three
Cubit poly operations there are exactly 16 of them in this category including the three that are mentioned on the screen and likewise for the other three
syndromes that's not obvious but it is true and this basic property that the syndromes partition both the state space
in which the encodings live and all of the possible polyer in the space into equal siiz pieces is something that's
true in general for stabilizer codes which will soon Define precisely although it's mostly just an aside at
this point it's worth mentioning that poly operations that commute with both stabilizer generators or equivalently
poly operations that result in the syndrome plus1 +1 but are not themselves proportional to elements of the stabilizer turn out to behave just like
single Cubit poly operations on The Logical Cubit that we encoded for example xxx commutes with
both stabilizer generators but it's not proportional to any element of the stabilizer and indeed it's clear if you
think about this code for a moment that the effect that this operation has on an encoding is equivalent to an X gate on
the logical Cubit that was encoded and again this is something that generalizes to all stabilizer codes now it's time to Define stabilizer
codes in general and the way that it works is that we do something completely analogous to what we just discussed for
the three-bit repetition code except that we pick different stabilizer generators which all refer to as P1
through PR for the sake of this explanation these stabilizer generators must all be n Cubit poly operations
where n is the number of cubits used for the encoding and we can't just pick any old set of stabilizer generators they
have to satisfy a few basic conditions first the stabilizer generators Must ALL commute with one
another in the case of the three-bit repetition code we didn't bother to take note of this but it is straightforward to observe that ZZ identity and identity
ZZ do in fact commute because Z commutes with itself and everything commutes with the
identity for stabilizer codes with more complicated stabilizer generators on the other hand including codes where we have
both x's and Z's appearing in the stabilizer generators this is an important condition that needs to be
checked one way to think about the need for this condition is that we're going to be treating the stabilizer generators as obs observables and by requiring that
they all commute we're ensuring that the order in which we perform these measurements doesn't
matter second the stabilizer generators must form a so-called minimal generating set which means that if we removed any
one of them we'd get a smaller stabilizer and one way to express this mathematically is shown here on the
screen strictly speaking this condition isn't really essential to the way that a stabilizer code Works in an operational
sense and sometimes it does make sense to think about non-minimal generating sets as we'll see in the next lesson but
for the sake of analyzing stabilizer codes and explaining their properties we're going to assume that this condition is in
place basically this condition guarantees that each observable that we measure to obtain the syndrome is adding
information about possible errors as opposed to being redundant and giving results that could easily be inferred from the other stabilizer generators as
observables and finally it must be the case that at least one nonzero Vector is fixed by all
of the stabilizer generators and that turns out to be equivalent to demanding that -1 time the identity on N cubits is
not contained in the stabilizer that's not obvious but the point is that it is possible to choose a minimal generating
set of n Cubit poly operations that all commute with one another and yet no Vector is simultaneously a plus one igen
vector of all of them and we don't want to concern ourselves with this possibility because codes where there aren't any valid encodings aren't
interesting so those are the requirements on the stabilizer generators for a stabilizer code and if we do have a set of generators that
satisfy these conditions then we have a valid stabilizer code and we can consider its properties there are many
different stabilizer codes with various properties that make them interesting or not but they all satisfy certain basic
properties that are reminiscent of the ones that we've already observed for the three-bit repetition code
we'll take a look at some examples shortly but before that let me mention that when we refer to the code space of a stabilizer code we mean the Subspace
of the N Cubit State space that includes every Vector that's simultaneously a plus one igen vector of every one of the
stabilizer generators this is the Subspace of the en Cubit State space in which valid encodings live and we'll have more to
say about this Subspace as the lesson continues now let's take a look at a few examples of stabiliz
codes here's the example we've already discussed the ordinary 3-bit repetition code and we can also Express the
modified version of that code from the previous lesson which can detect a phase flip instead of a bit flip as a stabilizer code AS is shown
here this time the stabilizer generators measure XX observables rather than ZZ observables so these are basically
parity checks in the plus minus basis rather than the standard basis in both cases we can can
immediately see that we have a valid stabilizer code because the stabilizer generators commute these are minimal
generating sets and the code space is non-trivial as we already know but we can also see pretty clearly that we
can't generate negative -1 time the identity and here's the 9 Cubit Shore code which is also a stabilizer code
expressed by stabilizer generators in this case we basically have three copies of the three- bit
repetition code one for each of the three blocks of three cubits as well as the last two stabilizer generators which
take a form that's reminiscent of the circuit that we saw in the previous lesson for detecting phase flips for this
code another way of thinking about these last two stabilizer generators is that they take exactly the same form as we
have for the three-bit repetition code for phase flips except that we substitute XXX for x and the reason for
that is that XXX corresponds to an X operation on The Logical Cubit encoded using the 3-bit repetition code but
that's an aside and it's not something to worry about right now in case it isn't clear next we'll take a look at a few
more examples but before that let me mention that people often omit the tensor product symbols when describing stabilizer codes because it tends to
make them easier to read so here's what these codes look like without the tensor product symbols
but of course these are tensor products and not ordinary Matrix products for instance we're just leading out the tensor product symbols so that it's less
cluttered and the patterns are more clear here's another example it's called
the 7 Cubit steam code and it has some pretty remarkable features we'll come back to this one
from time to time throughout the remaining lessons of the unit but for now we can simply verify that it is a valid stabilizer
code in particular the first three stabilizer generators clearly commute with one another because Z commutes with
itself and the identity commutes with everything and the situation is similar for the last three so it remains to
check that if we take one of the Z stabilizer generators and one of the X stabilizer generators then they commute
and it's easy enough to go through the nine possible pairings to check that in all of these cases we'll always
have an X and A Z matching up in the same position an even number of times so the two generators will commute just
like xx and ZZ commute it's a minimal generating set and it has a non-trivial code space but
I won't try to argue that in this video and instead I'll leave that for you to think about if you wish the 7 Cubit steam code is similar
to the 9 Cubit Shore code in the sense that it encodes a single Cubit and allows for the correction of an arbitrary error on one cubit but it only
requires seven cubits rather than nine that's not the fewest number of cubits required for an error correcting code to
encode a cubit and correct for an arbitrary error on on a single Cubit here's a stabilizer code that's
usually just called the five Cubit code that also encodes a single Cubit and can correct an arbitrary single Cubit error
and five is the smallest number of cubits for which this is possible here's another example of a
stabilizer code although it isn't really a code so to speak in the sense that the code space is
one-dimensional in particular the code space for this code is the space spend by an ebit or in other words a five plus
spell state so you can't actually encode any cubits using this code but it's still a valid stabilizer code where the code
space happens to be one-dimensional and it's possible to do something similar for a GHz
state so those are some examples of stabilizer codes and we'll see infinitely many more examples in the
next lesson suppose that we're given a stabilizer code a natural question to ask about it
perhaps the very first question that comes to mind is how many cubits does it encode that question has a very simple
answer and to explain it let's be precise about the stabilizer code being considered we have R and Cubit
stabilizer generators P1 through p r that satisfy the three requirements that I mentioned earlier namely that the
stabilizer generators all commute with one another this is a minimal generating set so we wouldn't get the same
stabilizer if we removed one of the generators and there's at at least one nonzero Vector in the code
space as the theorem shown on the screen indicates it must then be that the code space of the stabilizer code has
Dimension 2 ^ nus r or another way of saying that is that we can encode n
minus r cubits using this code So intuitively speaking we have n cubits in our encodings and each
stabilizer generator effectively takes a cubit away in terms of how many cubits we can encode
this theorem isn't too hard to prove and I'll show you a proof in just a moment but first we'll take a look at just a
few examples starting with the ordinary 3-bit repetition code we have three cubits in our
encodings so n is equal to three and there are R equals 2 stabilizer generators and so we can encode one
cubit using this code notice that this is not about which or how many errors can be detected or
corrected that's a different matter this is just a statement about the dimension of the codee
space for another example consider the 5 Cubit code here we have five cubits and four
stabilizer generators so once again the code space has Dimension two which means that we can encode one cubit using this
code and one more example for now for the ebit stabilizer code we have two cubits and two stabilizer generators so
the code space is one-dimensional and as I mentioned mentioned earlier it's the space span by the five plus Bell State
we'll see more examples as we continue on including codes where we can encode more than one cubit but for now let's
see how we can prove the theorem the first thing that we need to observe is that because the stabilizer
generators commute and form a minimal generating set and because every poly operation is its own inverse every
element in the stabilizer can be expressed in a unique way as a product where we raise each stabilizer generator
PK to the power AK where each AK is either Z or one and then we multiply the results
together another way to say this is that we get every element of the stabilizer by multiplying together some subset of
the stabilizer generators and we never get the same stabilizer element from different subsets and one thing that
this implies is that the only way to express the N Cubit identity operation in this way is to take all of the powers to be
zero next let's Define pi K to be the projection onto the plus one igen space of PK for each K from 1 to R and there's
a simple formula for this projection we can simply average PK with the identity on N cubits which effectively leaves the
plus one IG values alone and shifts all the minus one IG values to zero I
values now the code space is defined as the set of all vectors that are simultaneously plus one I vectors of all
of the stabilizer generators given that the stabilizer generators commute the projections must also commute and that
implies that the product of these projections is also a projection and in particular it's the projection onto the
intersection of the subspaces that the individual projections project onto or in other words it's the projection onto
the code space we can expand out this product and what we get is the average over every
element of the stabilizer and finally because the dimension of any Subspace is equal to
the trace of the projection onto that Subspace we find that the dimension of the code space is the average of the traces over the elements of the
stabilizer but with the exception of the ubit identity operation all of the elements of the stabilizer must have
Trace equal to zero because the three non-identity polym matrices all have Trace equal to zero the trace of the N Cubit identity
operation is 2 to the n and so we find that the dimension of the code space is 2 the nus r which proves the
theorem next I'll say just a little bit about how cubits can be encoded using stabilizer codes but to do that we first
need to introduce Clifford operations Clifford operations are unitary operations on any number of
cubits that can be implemented by Quantum circuits with a restricted set of gates namely hadamard Gates S Gates
and controlled knot Gates notice that t gates are not included nor are tofly Gates or fredin
Gates and not only are those Gates not included in this list but in fact it's not possible to implement those Gates
using the ones listed here so they're not Clifford operations poly operations on the other
hand are Clifford operations and specifically they can be implemented using sequences of hadam Art and Es
Gates so that's a simple way to define Clifford operations but it doesn't really explain why they're defined in
this way or what's special about this particular collection of gates here's the real reason that Clifford operations are defined like
this up to a global phase the ncub Clifford operations are precisely the unitary
operations that always transform poly operations into poly operations by conjugation to be more precise an nbit
unitary operation U is a Clifford operation up to a global phase Factor if and only if for every ncit poly
operation conjugating that poly operation by U gives us plus or minus one times some possibly different n
Cubit poly operation ation you can easily check that this property is true for hadamar Gates S
Gates and c not Gates so it necessarily holds for circuits built from these Gates what's harder to prove is that it
goes in the other direction which is that if we're given a particular nbit unitary operation U that satisfies this
property then it must be possible to implement it up to a global phase using just hadamard s and cot
Gates I won't go through the proof of that implication but it is true and you can look it up if you're
interested Clifford operations are not Universal for Quantum computation meaning that we can't run arbitrary
Quantum computations using just hadamard s and cot gates in fact for a given value of n there are only finitely many
n Cubit Clifford operations so it's a discrete set of operations so unlike a
universal set of quantum Gates we can't approximate arbitrary unitary operations to any desired level of accuracy and in
fact performing Clifford operations on standard basis States followed by standard basis measurements can't allow
us to perform computations that are outside of the reach of classical algorithms because we can efficiently simulate computations of this form
classically this fact is known as the goisman Kil theorem and the standard proof of that theorem is in some sense
based on the stabilizer formalism in particular the way that it works is that we can keep track of the way that Clifford operation transform poly
operations by conjugation which can be done efficiently and then infer from that what the computations do to
cubits so what does this have to do with stabilizer codes well a stabilizer code provides us
with a code space of a certain Dimension and we have the freedom to use that code space however we choose so nothing forces us to encode
cubits into that space in a specific way but it will always be possible ref form an encoding using a Clifford operation
as the encoder that's nice because Clifford operations are relatively simple compared with arbitrary unitary
operations there are ways to optimize their implementation which works along similar lines to the proof of the gsman
canil theorem and as a result circuits for implementing them never need to be all that
large in particular we can always perform an encoding using a Clifford operation that requires a little bit less than a quadratic number of gates
because that's actually true of every Clifford operation so the upshot is that for a given stabilizer code it's always
possible to encode cubits efficiently using that code and the mathematical tools that are useful for understanding Clifford operations can help with this
process for example here's an encoder for the 7 Cubit steam code it's a Clifford operation and as it turns out
this one doesn't even need S Gates for General stabilizer codes eror detection works in the following
way as before we'll assume that we have n Cubit stabilizer generators P1 through p r and we'll let e be an N Cubit poly
operation representing a hypothetical error on an encoding we're only considering poly
operations as Errors By the way because the discretization of Errors works in the same way for arbitrary stabilizer codes as it does for the 9 Cubit Shore
code the way that we check for errors is to measure each of the stabilizer generators as
observables there are R stabilizer generators so this means our outcomes where each one is a plus one or a minus
one or a binary value if you prefer to associate zero with plus one and one with minus one and these R outcomes
together form the syndrome just like we had for the three-bit repetition code when R was equal to
two in general there are three possible cases for the error e in terms of its detection and they are as follows first
it could be that e is in the stabilizer meaning that is possible to generate E from the stabilizer generators or
slightly more generally it could be that e is equivalent to a stabilizer element up to a global
phase in this case e isn't really an error at all because it has no effect in the code space other than to possibly
inject a global phase which doesn't have any effect so we don't need to worry at all about errors like this whatever
non-trivial action it might have happens outside of the code space so it doesn't concern
us much more of a concern is the possibility that e is not in the stabilizer even up to a global phase but
nevertheless it does commute with every single one of our stabilizer generators remember that it's the
anti-commutation of the error with a stabilizer generator that causes a minus one to appear somewhere in the syndrome
but that doesn't happen in this case so this is an error that actually does change vectors in the code space in some
non-al way and we know this because otherwise it would be proportional to a stabilizer element but it goes
undetected by the code so this is the bad case we have an error that may potentially be changing
whatever Quantum information we've encoded but the code is oblivious to this fact for example for the three-bit
repetition code XXX falls into this category and the last possibility is that the a e
anti-c commutes with at least one of the stabilizer generators and this means that the code detects this error because
we'll get a syndrome with at least one minus one somewhere in it which indicates that something is wrong and we'll need to try to correct this error
somehow so those are the possibilities as a point of terminology
when we refer to the distance of a stabilizer code what we mean is the minimum weight of a poly operation falls
into the second category meaning that it changes the code space in some non-trivial way but the code doesn't
detect this and when we say that a stabilizer code is an nmd stabilizer code using
double square brackets as is shown on the screen what that means is that encodings are n cubits in length the
code is capable of encoding M cubits so the code space has Dimension 2 the m and its distance is D so an error has to
have weight weit D or more to change the logical state of whatever Cubit we've been coded without being detected as an
error we'll now take a look at the 7 Cubit steam code as an example and we'll determine what its distance
is here are the stabilizer generators for this code and recall that the distance is the minimum weight of an
encubate poly operation that commutes with all of the stabilizer generators but is itself not in the stabilizer nor
is it proportional to an element of the stabilizer what we'll determine is that this code has distance
three the way that we'll determine this is to First consider any poly operation having weight at most two and we'll
conclude that the only way that it can compute with all six stabilizer generators is for to be the identity which is always an element of the
stabilizer so let's suppose that the possibly non-identity polym matricies that form this operation which we'll
call P and Q appear in the leftmost two positions this is just one case and we do have to
consider all of the other possible locations for these possibly non-identity poly matrices but the argument is basically the same for all
of the possible locations well by assumption this operation commutes with all sticks
stabilizer generators so in particular it commutes with this one and it also commutes with this
one Q lines up with the identity Matrix in both of these generators which is why we chose these two and we have identity
Matrix IES in the rightmost five positions of this error and so we conclude that P must commute with both x
and z because otherwise this error would anticommute with one of these two generators but the only polymatrix that
commutes with both x and z is the identity so P must be the identity and now that we know that we
can choose two more stabilizer generators that have an X and a z in the second position from left and we can
draw a similar conclusion about Q so there's no way for a weight atmost 2 error to go undetected by this code
unless it's just the identity operation which is in the stabilizer so this isn't actually an
error on the other hand there are weight three poly operations that commute with all six of these stabilizer generators
but aren't proportional to stabilizer elements and here are two examples so we've concluded that this
code has distance three the last thing that we'll discuss in this lesson is correcting errors for
stabilizer codes as usual we'll assume our code is specified by nbit stabilizer generators
P1 through p and let's start by thinking a little bit about all of the possible errors that could take
place there are two to the r possible syndromes and as I mentioned earlier in the lesson these syndromes partition all
of the possible en cupit poly operations into equal siiz collections so that means 4 the N / 2 the r poly operations
within each set so when we see a particular syndrome it could be that any one of these four to the N divided by 2
to the r errors is responsible we are overcounting a little bit here though because some of these
errors have exactly the same effect on the code space in particular if we have an error E and we multiply e By Any
stabilizer element s then we're going to get another error that has exactly the same effect in the code space as e so
these are equivalent errors the stabilizer has two to the r elements and if we account for this then we find
that for each syndrome there are four to the N minus r INE equivalent classes of errors that could have caused that one
syndrome and what that means is that unless R is equal to n in which case we have a one-dimensional code space and
therefore can't encode any cubits at all it's not going to be possible to correct every error that we can detect instead
what we have to do is choose just one correction operation for each syndrome in the hopes of correcting just one class of equivalent
errors so how should we choose what correction to perform for each syndrome a natural strategy is to choose
the lowest weight poly operation that causes whatever syndrome we measure with the idea being that lower weight poly
operations represent more likely explanations for that syndrome this might not actually be the
case for some noise models and another natural strategy is to somehow compute the most likely error that causes the
given syndrome but for now we'll just consider the strategy where we attempt to correct errors by selecting the lowest weight poly operation causing the
syndrome for a distance D stabilizer code this strategy will always allow us to correct errors having weight strictly
less than half of D or in other words weight at most D minus1 over2 and I'll explain briefly why this
is this will show for instance that the 7 Cubit steam code can correct for any weight one poly error and by the
discretization of errors this means that just like the 9 Cubit Shore code the steam code can correct for an arbitrary
error on one cubit so here's how this works consider that this circle represents all of the possible poly
operations that result in the all plus1 syndrome which is the syndrome that suggests that no errors have occurred
and nothing is wrong among these operations we have elements of the stabilizer or really
operations that are proportional to elements of the stabilizer and we also have non-trivial errors that change the code space somehow but they aren't
detected by the code and We Know by the definition of distance that every poly operation in this category must have weight at least
D because D is defined as the minimum weight of these operations we also have poly operations
that cause other syndromes to appear and we could consider each syndrome in turn if we wish but here we're just imagining
that one such syndrome s has appeared now imagine that e is an eror in this
category that has weight strictly less than half of the distance D well we don't know that this is
necessarily the minimum weight poly operation in this circle so let's take C to be the minimum weight operation in this set or one of them in case there's
a tie so it could be that c is equal to e or possibly not but because C has
minimum weight we know that it can't possibly have weight larger than the weight of E because C is also in the set
and it has minimal weight so the correction operation C must have weight strictly less than half of
D so what happens if we apply this correction C to whatever our state becomes after the air e
occurs the answer is that the state that we obtain is C * e multiplied to the original encoding because we first
multiply by E that was the error and then we multiplied by C to try to correct it and this product must be in
the stabilizer or proportional to an element of the stabilizer and here's why first because e and C give us the
same syndrome C * e must give us the all plus one syndrome that's because for a given
stabilizer generator either c and e both commute with that generator or they both anticommute it has to be the same for
both because the syndromes are the same and if you think about that for just a moment it implies that c * e must
commute with all the stabiliz generators and finally C * e has to be
down in the stabilizer because its weight can't be larger than the sum of the weights of c and e and so its weight
is strictly less than D and this means that we successfully correct e because applying e followed by C does nothing to
the code space so that's great but there's just one problem and that is that for stabilizer
codes in general it's a computationally difficult problem to compute the lowest weight operation causing a given
syndrome and indeed that's true even for classical codes which in this context we can think about as stabilizer codes
where we only have identity matrices and polyc matrices appearing as tensor factors within the stabilizer
generators so unlike the encoding step Clifford operations don't come to our rescue this time and the only reasonable
solution is to choose specific codes for which good Corrections can be computed efficiently and there's no recipe for
this simply put devising stabilizer codes like this is part of the Artistry
of Quantum Code design and that is a good place to stop for this lesson I hope you will join me
for the next lesson in which we'll take a look at some specific Quantum Code constructions including codes that illustrate the Artistry of Quantum Code
design in a pretty spectacular way goodbye for now